wenn dieses video 20.000 likes bekommt
drehe ich ein musikvideo zu alex wie
500.000 abonnenten special 321 etwas
gedacht jetzt willkommen bei einem neuen
video ich hoffe euch geht es gut mir
auch irgendwie wird der anfang immer
komisch was geht ab heute mit ihr seht
es wahrscheinlich schon einer etwas
anderen kamera das ding ist mit der
kamera die ich normalerweise aufnehme
hieß weg hat mein mitbewohner in seinem
rucksack und das nicht da also bleibt
mir nichts anderes übrig als dieses
video mit meiner eigentlichen long
qingquan aufzunehmen die auch um ehrlich
zu sein echt sehr gut ist vor allem wenn
man dann noch dieses licht daran hört
ihr seht wahrscheinlich gerade alle
hautunreinheiten an mir die ich sonst
nicht mal selber sehe wenn man in den
spiegel guckt weil diese kamera so gut
ist aber egal darum geht es heute gar
nicht wir sind ja hier ausschließlich
nicht beim beauty contest sondern bei
einem neuen video von alex heute wo soll
ich anfangen ich habe mir gedacht
eigentlich kann ich dieses projekt nicht
unveröffentlicht lassen ich bin dass es
nach spanien geflogen und hatte da mein
laptop dabei dieses ding hier
und den habe ich jetzt ungefähr
eineinhalb jahre und will einfach mal so
alle musikstücke durchgegangen die ich
hier drauf haben
warum ich das darauf aber nicht haben
wir auch meine rost yourself challenge
roth
[Musik]
und so weiter und wir haben auch das
ideale 500.000 abonnenten special von
mir also zumindest das audio davon zu
einem dreh ist nie wirklich gekommen
also um ehrlich zu sein das projekt
wurde jetzt auch nicht komplett
fertiggestellt wir sind einfach so also
ein freund von mir und ich wir sind auf
die idee gekommen diese sache zu
produzieren eigentlich war es mehr so
eine schnapsidee und wir wollten mal
gucken was rauskommt und ich wusste gar
nicht mehr dass dieses projekt noch
existiert ich habe es ja auch nicht
hochgeladen
es gab keinen 500.000 abonnenten special
ich habe es allerdings einen pfleger
ganz zufällig gefunden hab mir das schon
mal angehört und habe mir gedacht
dazu musst du eigentlich meine kleine
reaction drehen weil es eigentlich schon
lustig ist deswegen würde ich sagen ich
schicke das ganze jetzt hier mal kurz
auf meinen anderen pc weil der hat
einfach besser boxen und so und dann
schauen wir einfach mal wie sich das
anhört und ich bin auch wirklich mal
sehr gespannt was ihr dazu sagt es ist
absolut kein logisches meisterwerk man
kann sich schon darüber lustig machen
ein bisschen über den text und so aber
ich habe es ja auch nie veröffentlicht
wir haben das alles an einem abend
schnell aufgenommen und so ein bisschen
aus spaß wenn man die kommentare was
ihrem track gut findet und was überhaupt
nicht gut ich bin ja auch kein musiker
und wenn ihr gar nicht gut findet ist
das auch vollkommen okay aber ich will
jetzt hier gar nicht lange um den heißen
brei herum land deswegen fangen wir
sofort mal an
bei 21
[Musik]
also man muss hier erstmal sagen ich
hatte ja damals wann ist das entstanden
ungefähr vor einem jahr vor eineinhalb
jahren hatte ich 500.000 abonnenten und
er vorne im jahr ungefähr und ich dachte
mir so okay was kann man machen damit
man schnellstmöglich eine million hat
und dann bin ich halt auch diese
textzeile gekommen leider habe ich immer
noch keine eine million aber immer
optimistisch bleiben irgendwann wird das
schon jetzt unter knackig die millionen
an sich die melodie ist ja schon gar
nicht mehr so also den beat fand ich
persönlich ganz cool
[Musik]
okay er würde jetzt am liebsten
vorstellen also die strophe ist textlich
und ja vom rap stil her oder von der
stimmlage katastrophal das sehe ich
vollkommen genauso wie die meisten von
euch wahrscheinlich aber wir lassen uns
davon jetzt gar nicht beirren waren
einfach mal weiter
[Musik]
sie sagen weil jesus sind ziemlich
beliebt
[Musik]
das kann man eigentlich schon als comedy
sehen oder ok
[Musik]
das ist dieser typ von youtube und dann
sage ich halt manchmal einfach kuku okay
das ist jetzt kommt so ein kleiner
übergang zum refrain der wirklich ball
also den habe ich mir selber ausgedacht
leute das finde ich auch immer noch gar
nicht mal schlecht und zwar von 100.000
200.000 300.000 zu halben millionen
[Musik]
das gleiche 500 gab ja mit autotune dann
passt das von der stimme her gerade war
ich wieder ein bisschen also schreibt
meine ehrliche meinung jetzt in die
kommentare was sagt ihr so bis jetzt
würdet ihr sagen okay da kann man ein
auge zudrücken das kann man sich
eventuell anhören bis auch die strophe
jetzt oder sagte story alex hier bin ich
raus das ist ein absoluter schwachsinn
[Musik]
ja ich hab ja ich habe jetzt 500 k
und ich weiß doch genau die ist mit
hunderten war mal innerlich doch meine
absicht
das problem ist auch immer wenn man
irgendwas es kann noch so scheiße sein
wenn man schon so 30 40 mal gehört hat
kann man irgendwann gar nicht mehr sagen
ob das jetzt komplett grausam ist oder
ok wegen also ich würde dem gesamtpaket
so objektiv betrachtet obwohl es bei
musik natürlich immer sehr schwer würde
ich dem ganzen vielleicht so eine drei
minus geben und jetzt kommen wieder mein
lieblings part
[Musik]
zur halben millionen
okay ich mache auch hier kurzen stopp
und ich würde sagen wenn dieses video
20.000 likes bekommt drehe ich ein
musikvideo zu alex wie 500.000
abonnenten special zwar schon natürlich
überhaupt nicht mehr aktuell aber das
spielt keine rolle wenn ihr darauf
gehabt lassen nach oben da 20.000 likes
ist meine ansage wenn man es schaffen
witzig wenn wir es nicht schaffen dann
halt nicht und wir haben jetzt noch mal
so schön entspannt zu ende
[Musik]
und jetzt 100 jahre
ich habe 100 k
dollar knapp 100 km
ok jetzt werde es sofort vorbei das
ganze geht moment
[Musik]
zwei minuten 56 steht am anfang gesagt
sowohl physisch als auch melancholisch
ein absolutes meisterwerk ich wollte
euch einfach mal zeigen ich meine das
ist ja eine sehr lustige änderung wie
sich das so entwickelt hat bei mir auf
'youtube' leider ist es nicht online
gekommen oder was er ist leider ist
wahrscheinlich besser aber deswegen
jetzt das angebot von meiner seite wenn
ihr bock habt dass sich das vielleicht
mal veröffentlichen sollte mit video und
so weiter das 20.000 daumen nach oben da
steht auf jeden fall snapshot und
instagram ab und wir sehen uns dann
vermutlich morgen wieder gibt es neues
video
drei leute und ich haben wir eure ohren
sind jetzt nicht allzu geschädigt